yellow welcome to this video this is a
very different doesn't have a chessboard
in it it's um a little personal thing
I've added something recently and this
is some Twitter account which i used to
get two new videos posted so if you want
to get informed about new uploads and
while other things that I might tweet
it's mostly about the video uploads but
I'll occasionally em read something to
other players on or comment on something
if you like that you can follow me on
Twitter it's the the name you would
expect its twitter com chess explained
I've also put butter than the Lincoln in
the description so if you if you like
twitter you can follow me and then you
get informed about new uploads instantly
it's pretty nice if you are I'm just
scrolling through this so if I got a new
video uploaded it instantly creates a
post here it's really am basically the
second the video is on youtube the Sun
Twitter thing is posted so you can also
directly jump to the video for instance
here i uploaded something today Bureau
10 you just go on the video and it
instantly jumps to this thing you can
watch it right here or watch it on
youtube so it's a pretty convenient and
I think quite a quite a nice addition
maybe that can help you to to keep on
track what I'm what I'm uploading and
what I'm what else I'm tweeting here so
on yeah follow me then get them quite a
quite a nice feature I'm trying to
figure out this twitter thing it's it's
pretty new to me so if you see something
that might look look a bit weird so just
tell me yeah thanks for watching and
yeah follow me on twitter